I'm Owen Flanagan
so just do good I've been trying to
change analysis mad dog for a long time
so good luck but dan and I will try so I
actually been interested I guess I could
start with what Alex said is I've always
been interested in this question about
sellers has this quote that a lot of us
naturalist and philosophy use where he
says that philosophy is the attempt to
think about how things hang together in
how things conceived up in the broadest
possible sense hang together in the
broadest possible sense and as some of
the people have said I mean it would be
nice to have a unified theory about how
things work and it does seem that as a
cultural project one of the problems is
somehow meshing if we can are a
scientific understanding of things with
what is best preserved from common sense
so I'm interested I've always been
interested in that project
autobiographically maybe it's relevant
to say I grew up as a good little
Catholic boy interested in questions
like why's there why is there whether
there is what about reward and
Punishment and what about freedom and
what about what happens after life and
in the same section of the world where
Rebecca was growing up was a nice Jewish
girl probably asking the same questions
but in a different context and so I was
I would this by the time I
I became I was in college I was
interested in what I came to see is
primarily scientific questions about how
did how did life emerge hadn't sentient
life emerge and so I did increasingly go
to the sciences by the time I finished
college
my teachers half of them thought that I
should go on in philosophy and having
fun
experimental psychology I realized if I
had gone on an experimental psychology I
wanted to do brain science but there
really wasn't in 1970 brain science it
was still something before that so I did
the next best thing and I've been
attached to the naturalistic program
since then I studied with willard van
orman quine and some of his students and
and my conception of naturalism has been
this idea that the best philosophy is
continuous with the best science perhaps
in the more general level the specific
problems I've been interested in are the
problem of consciousness and my attitude
about consciousness is that by the
mid-1990s when after people like Dan and
myself and a few other people
philosophers had their say about saying
consciousness could be made safe for
science that our work as philosophers
was pretty much done and then it's just
empirical questions of working out the
scientific details and I'm disturbed by
the way philosophers continued to go on
and moan and groan about the hard
problem and the impossibility and
conceivabilities thought experiments and
what if there and and it's disturbing to
me about my own field the other area
besides consciousness I've been
interested in and this is again work I
did in the early 90s was on ethics and
always been interested in this question
of
whether or not so I read a book around
the same time I wrote a book on
consciousness on what I called varieties
of moral personality ethics and
psychological realism and it was and the
idea was that ethics could be
naturalized there was just no problem
there was no reason to think that we had
to think of morality either in
Supernatural istic terms or in morally
realistic terms or as my general view is
what in is roughly that you know
morality is just another social
institution and due to the certain bad
effects of theological traditions we've
come to think of it as something which
requires a separate sort of explanation
I continue to work on that I think that
I'm always very curious about the way
that everybody gets the heebie-jeebies
about what they allege to be Humes
problem the problem of normativity the
problem of how you derive is from off
the answer is you don't derive
instrument because that would be a
fallacy but you can make inferences the
best explanation about what you ought to
do or what is reasonable to do or what
will make life go best or what it
enhances well-being and there are often
competing goods about this the these two
interests in naturalizing mind and
naturalizing morality have led me in
some recent work and this is back to the
little boy that I once was to what I
call the really hard problems and I
think these are really hard problems for
natural ists
what I call mind morals in the meaning
of life and by that I just mean making
this is partly a cultural project of
taking seriously the fact that most of
our compatriots on earth are not or at
least in America start with just America
have trouble seeing how life could make
sense or to be meaningful if the world
is as most of the people around the
table think and I try in some of my most
recent work to give a kind of an upbeat
explanation of how it's possible to find
meaning in a fully material world one
other interest I have closed with what I
could change my mind about is I'm
actually very interested in the way
other traditions conceive of the world
the natural world the place of science
in it and whether they have the same
problems as us so for example I I've
been working for a long time recently
well for a long time sort of secretly
and then lately more publicly in
classical Chinese and classical Indian
philosophy and so I'm be interested in
the discussions of freewill here because
I am one of those people who think that
it's a black hole and philosophy and
that other cultures happily avoid
discussing it and it just doesn't come
up and I'm thinking here of Hindu and
Buddhist traditions classical Chinese
philosophy it just doesn't come up and
some people are trying to say here's
what Buddhists would think if they
talked about free will and I'm saying
shut up don't even talk about it they're
better off or not even bringing it up so
I'll be I have some things to say about
that
and finally what I would change my mind
about so I've been there's a literature
in psychology that maybe people in this
room know about I know Dan certainly
knows better
I'm sure Rebecca this - it's a
literature on what's called positive
illusions and the positive illusion
literature basically says something like
this that you know the findings are
things like this that you you introduce
you give a public health lecture at the
beginning of you know the Stanford
undergraduates arrive and you say you
women in the room the chances of getting
breast cancer in your life or one an
eighth so here are some things you can
do for breast health and men it's one a
day for prostate cancer here's some
things you should do for prostate and
then you ask the students afterwards
what is the probability of you getting
having the bad thing
and always in the population you they
get back much lower rates of believing
that this thing will happen to them then
they should get back obviously some
people will know they're late greater or
lesser risk but in a population you
should get back the base rate which you
just reported to these smart people and
the findings are that you never get back
the base rate you get back lower and
then when they pull out the subgroups
this is the allegation that when you
pull out these different groups the only
group that are what they call realists
about things are people who are
moderately depressed the people who are
very depressed of course think they
already have the disease but I think
this is interesting now dan has given an
explanation of trying to argue that
these kind of positive illusions are our
adaptive I think that's preposterous but
it's really a hope I have more than
anything else I'd like to think that
maybe these things are hopes instead of
beliefs in which case they'd be less
rational it's kind of like I'm not
answering the question who I believe
that I won't get that I'm saying I hope
I don't get that so but I've been
working in this for a long time and I
can't get back out of the way and the
reason they're relevant to a group like
this and this is what I could change my
mind about steven weinberg many years
ago when I read one of his wonderful
articles I think Steven said something
like it's obvious and it's that religion
has done more harm than good and that's
the view I tend to have and I tend to
have the view that believing false
things does always more harm than good
but I worry about my belief there I
worry about that belief and so I guess I
the thing to say is what I could change
my mind about I get stuck in that middle
easily some days I think false beliefs
are always the enemy and then when I
speak to the front of psychologists they
say you philosophers are weird and maybe
you scientists refer to you care about
the truth most people don't care about
the truth and it's actually even bad for
them so I think that these are this is a
topic where I can go either way
and I'd love to sit here and get your
wisdom on so do you know what the
students would say if they if they were
asked why do you think you'll have a 2%
chance even though we told you it's one
in eight you know there's a lot of I've
read a lot of this literature over time
JB Dan could speak to that I don't know
what they say they people tell me it
really that the my explanation which
tries to give the they hope it's a it's
a it's a misattribution they're really
hoping it rather than belief believing
it you think you could get that right
Sean by doing further study I don't
remember the last time I looked at this
research whether anyone's done the
further study I don't know yeah so thank
you
you